and this is what major should you choose
if you want to apply to a firm like
McKinsey and what you can clearly see
here is that business type of major such
as Business Administration Management
economics Finance these are very
competitive very relevant Majors if you
want to apply to a firm like McKinsey
and indeed and this is too awesome very
much from my experience than the second
most often are technical Mint type of
subjects your for instance mechanical
engineering computer science electrical
engineering and here at least from my
subjective perception I would have
believed that this share of Mint type of
degrees is even higher for the
Consultants at mbb